Welcome back, aspiring professional
Python devs to mCoding, I'm James Murphy.
Let's learn how to set up logging in
your python application, the modern way.
That means we're going to learn to stop
doing this, and start doing this instead.
As always with so-called "best
practices" these are general guidelines
that work for most use cases.
However, you know what's best for
your code way better than I do,
so if you have a good reason,
then do what you know is right.
Don't blindly follow this advice
if it doesn't work for you.
With that said, let's get going
... right after I sponsor myself.
At mCoding, we do code reviews,
consulting, and professional training.
Do you have a problem with your code?
Worried about your architecture?
Or do you just need some extra dev hours?
Why not make me part of your team?
Anyway let's get back to logging.
The built-in logging package is very old
and full of stuff that you shouldn't use.
It doesn't follow PEP8, the docs are a mess,
and many tutorials are outdated or quite frankly
written by people who obviously don't use it.
But for all its quirks, the
built-in logging package is
the de-facto standard for logging in Python.
It doesn't matter if you're using a cloud
provider or just developing a local application,
the standard is the built-in logging package.
But do you really even need logging at all?
Hey man, you came to me.
If your app doesn't need logging, that's up to
you, I'm just here to show you what's possible.
All right, let's see how to get started.
You might think you just import logging,
make a logger, set it up with a basic config,
and then get to logging with your messages.
When you run the code, based off the log level
you set, you see those level messages and worse.
And I wouldn't blame you if
you've been doing it this way.
In the most basic cases this is totally fine,
but I don't really recommend doing it this way.
Why? Well, if you care to do logging
at all you probably want to log
to at least two different places,
like to stdout and also to a file.
Or you want to log higher priority things
like errors and exceptions differently,
maybe you want to send an email if
there's an exception thrown in prod?
You can manually make handlers and
filters and add them to your loggers,
but, trust me, just don't do it that way.
Instead, use dictConfig.
For some reason dictConfig is hidden
away in this logging.config submodule,
and not so much as mentioned
in the main logging docs.
As the name suggests, this lets you
configure logging via a dictionary
that explicitly lists all of the necessary
components of your logging setup,
namely the filters, formatters,
handlers, and loggers.
The basic config hides these objects
and their relationships from you,
which makes for a really slick
one-liner in the most basic case,
but for more useful logging setups I find
it's much clearer to list them explicitly.
It can get really confusing if you don't have a
good mental model for what
these things actually do.
So here's the one picture to keep in
mind to see how it all fits together.
Loggers are the things that
you actually use in your code.
They have a ".info" and you can
call logger.info to log a message,
logger.debug to log a debug message,
logger.exception to log the
in-flight exception, etc.
That creates a log record,
which is an object that contains all
kinds of useful contextual information.
Things like the message and
severity, the current time,
the current thread or async task, the
location in the source code, and so on.
Every logger can set a level to drop
all messages below a certain severity,
and optionally some filters to drop
or alter messages along the way.
So you could do something like drop all
messages that begin with "some annoying string."
Or you could do something more sophisticated
like sensor private user data that
isn't supposed to appear in logs.
The logger then passes these log records
off to each of their handlers one at a time.
Handlers tell you how and where
to log a record, like to stdout,
to a file. over email. or
to a commercial log service.
Each handler receives the log record and,
just like for loggers, the handler has a level
and some filters that allow it to drop
or alter the message along the way.
if a record is dropped by a handler, it
still passes on to the rest of the handlers.
But if it was dropped by the logger
itself, then it's dropped for good.
Assuming the message passes
through the levels and filters,
when it comes time for the handler to actually
write the log message, it needs to write text.
But currently this is a Python object.
So each handler has a formatter
that it uses to convert the log record
object into a string to be sent out.
The formatter is what lets you customize
what an individual message looks like.
Like is it the log level and then the message?
Or level, then timestamp, then message?
Or maybe you write JSON, or maybe
you write some other format.
Formatters are typically where
you see the most customization
because it's the formatter
that selects which data from
the log record to actually include in the message
and that depends a lot on your specific use
case and what you want to see in your logs.
And this is almost the complete picture.
Except this is the picture for the root logger,
the root as in the root of the tree of loggers.
Loggers are accessed and created by name,
and if you split the name by dots then
you end up with a tree of loggers.
So the A.X logger is a child of the A
logger, which is a child of the root.
By default, once a child's done handling a log
record, it passes that record up to its parent.
So if this log record was generated
down here in the A.X logger,
all of A.X's handlers would run,
then it would propagate up to A,
and all of A's handlers would run,
then it would propagate up to the root
and all of the roots handlers would run.
This is done to make it easier for users
to disable messages from whole subsystems
just by disabling certain loggers.
Once again, if a record is dropped by
a handler it will continue moving on,
to include propagating up to the parent.
But if it's dropped by a logger,
then it stops and doesn't propagate.
But slow down there, this is way more
flexibility than you would usually need.
Having all these handlers and filters
and propagation at different levels
is unnecessarily complex for most use cases.
And it often leads to subtly broken configs.
So here's what I recommend.
See all these non-root handlers? Delete them.
Unless you've got a good reason,
put all handlers on the root logger.
This is simpler, but also having all
handlers on the root logger ensures
that any messages generated by third-party
libraries get logged and formatted
the same way as messages
generated by your own application.
Filters? Same deal.
There's a decent chance you
don't need any filters at all,
but if you do put them all on the root logger
or their handlers.
Leave propagation turned on, which is the default,
so that all messages propagate
up to the root logger.
However, don't use the root logger in your code.
If you use any of the top-level logging functions
like logging.info, this uses is the root logger.
So don't use any of those functions.
Make sure to use your own logger, which you get by
using logging.getLogger and passing in
the name of the logger that you want.
This will create the logger first
if it doesn't already exist,
then you can use your logger.info
instead of logging.info.
And remember, your logger
doesn't have any handlers on it.
We're depending on propagation to
send all events up to the root logger
and have the root logger
actually handle the events.
If you have a small- to medium-sized application,
a single non-root logger is all you need.
If you have a very large application,
then you should make one non-root logger for
each major subcomponent of your application.
You definitely don't need a logger for every file.
That'd be a waste because these are globals
that live for the entire life of the program.
With that all in mind, let's get back
to configuring logging for a few
common setups using dictConfig.
As a baseline let's just have a simple
config that logs everything to stdout.
If you're ever confused about the config,
draw it out like this and then use
the picture to fill in the config.
This "version" is required
and the only valid value is 1.
This is so that they can change everything
in the future without breaking old code.
"disable_existing_loggers" does what it says,
it disables anything that's not
explicitly listed in this config.
I'm going to go ahead and set this to false so
that I can get log messages from third-party code.
No filters in this configuration,
so let's just delete that.
Next define a formatter named "simple"
and give it a simple format string.
We didn't specify what class this formatter is,
so by default it just uses the
built-in logging.Formatter.
It accepts the format string like this, using
this kind of weird printf-style format string.
Yes it's kind of weird but just deal with it or,
foreshadowing, wait a minute
and we'll see a better way.
If you want to customize your own
format you can find a list of all
the available variables in
the logging documentation.
Next we need to define the single stdout handler,
so we create this single handler named "stdout"
and set our "simple" formatter as
the formatter for this handler.
In order to get it to actually
log to stdout, we set its class to
the built-in logging stream handler
with a stream of sys.stdout.
The "ext://" slash here means "external",
as in this is a variable that's
defined outside of this config.
And voila! In just 16 lines we've configured
what the basic config did in one line.
I know, I know, but keep in mind this more of
verbose style is going to be a lot
clearer when we have more going on.
So stick with me.
Despite the fact that we're using dictConfig,
that doesn't mean that we need to
keep the logging configuration as
a literal dictionary in our Python source.
Nothing wrong with that,
but many find it convenient
to keep the logging config in a
separate file in JSON or YAML format.
Personally I prefer to keep my config in JSON, so
go ahead and create a JSON version of your config,
then load that JSON when
when your application starts.
If you wanted to use YAML instead,
it would look basically the same except
of course you would have a YAML config
and you would "import yaml" and do
a YAML load instead of a JSON load.
Let's bring those side by side just
so you can see the two configs.
Obviously YAML is a lot more condensed, but I
find it to be a lot more error-prone as well.
And also there's no YAML parser built into Python,
whereas there is a built-in JSON parser.
So if you wanted to, you would have
to pull that in as a dependency.
"pyyaml" is a popular choice.
Keeping the log config in a separate
file also allows you to let your users
adjust the logging config to their preference.
You know, if you trust your
users to do that kind of thing.
Second setup. Let's modify the
config so that errors go to stderr,
and then all logs go to a file.
Change the "stdout" handler to "stderr"
and set its level to "WARNING".
Then, create a new handler and set
its class to a RotatingFileHandler.
A rotating file handler keeps appending logs
to a file until it reaches a certain size,
in this case 10 kilobytes.
After it reaches 10 kilobytes, it
creates a backup and starts a new file.
After three backups it starts
deleting the oldest one.
10 kilobytes is a pretty small limit, this is
just so that you can see the rollover happen.
You probably want to pick a few megabytes.
After running the script a bunch of
times, you can see it eventually created
this "my_app.log.1" and then
started using "my_app.log" again.
We're still using the "simple" formatter here.
But since we're saving to a log file,
why don't we include some extra details?
We accomplish that by adding this new "detailed"
formatter and setting it as the
formatter for the "file" handler.
We include much more information in the format
string, and we're also showing
off the "datefmt" format here,
which allows us to customize
how dates are printed.
Pro tip: use an ISO-8601-compliant format
and include the timezone. Trust me.
This way our log contains a lot
more useful contextual information.
For a lot of applications,
this is a great place to stop.
But, if you really care about
the quality of your log data,
then I really suggest making one crucial change.
Take a look at this log file.
Glancing over it I can visually distinguish
different messages from each other,
but notice that we have tracebacks in here.
And what if log messages had newlines in them?
If I wanted to parse this programmatically
I'd need to be able to parse back out
all of the data that I put into it.
But it's kind of just in free-form text with
newlines that could be anywhere at this point.
That's kind of intractable.
The solution? Store persistent
logs in JSON format,
so that they can be parsed easily later on.
This is a change in how to convert
a log record into a string,
so that's the job of the formatter,
we need a JSON formatter.
But oh wait, there's no
built-in logging JSON formatter.
There are a few you can pip install,
but let's just write our own.
Supposing we did, you'd think you'd
be able to just set the "class" key
here and then pass in whatever arguments here,
and those will be keyword
arguments to the constructor.
That's what's happening here
with the handler, right?
Uhh, nope.
You can use your own class
here using the "class" keyword,
but if you do then all of the keys are
hardcoded to be the ones that the built-in uses/
So I could use "format" and "datefmt",
but I couldn't create my own "fmt_keys".
Why is it like this way?
Great question! Moving on.
Change "class" to "()" and then
it will do what you actually want:
call this and pass this as a keyword argument.
You'd have to do the same thing
anywhere else in the config,
like if I made my own custom handler that didn't
have the same interface as the built-in one.
Okay well with that weird road bump
out of the way, let's continue.
So we're going to pass in these format keys,
which is going to be a dictionary where the key is
the key that I want to appear in the log message,
and the value here, like "levelname",
is the variable that we're going
to look up from the log record.
Okay so let's go ahead and write this class.
We're in a new file here and we just
inherit from the built-in loging Formatter.
Nothing special in the init, we just store
the format keys that we get from the config.
Then we need to define this "format" function.
This is a thing that takes the
record and goes to a string.
I'm using "@override" here to indicate that
we're overriding something from the parent class.
It's not strictly necessary, but it's a
good habit to get into marking these things.
All we do is extract out the record data into a
dictionary and then use the "json"
module to dump that to a string.
As far as actually extracting those
fields goes, it's pretty simple.
Regardless of the config, I chose to include the
message and a timestamp in
ISO format in UTC timezone.
We pull in any exception data if
it's present using some parent
methods in order to extract things out nicely.
And for the rest of the keys we just grab
them from the attributes of the record.
It's pretty straightforward and you
could probably do whatever you want here.
And donzo! Update the config to use the
new JSON formatter and we're good to go.
Check our log file and we
see nicely formatted JSON.
A slight warning though,
this file is not valid JSON.
Each line is valid JSON.
This format is called JSON Lines and
the common file extension is ".jsonl".
So to parse it you just read the file
line by line and parse each line as JSON.
And double pro-tip: now
that we're outputting JSON,
it's actually really easy to add
lots of extra contextual information.
To do this we can just use the "extra"
argument in one of our log calls.
Give it a dictionary of extra information and
Python will stuff that onto the log record.
Then just update your formatter to pull in those
extra attributes and now any
extras will appear in our JSON.
Here's the .
If you're getting too many logs and you'd
like finer control over which ones to drop,
then you might need a filter.
The process of creating a custom filter is
very similar to creating a custom formatter.
Inherit from the built-in Filter, then define
your own override of the "filter" function.
Given a record, you return a bool to indicate
whether or not that record should be processed.
So this non-error filter does kind of the
opposite of setting the level to "INFO".
Setting the level to "INFO" would mean
that you would only keep messages that
were "INFO", "WARNING", "ERROR", "CRITICAL",
but setting this non-error filter would
give you "DEBUG" and "INFO" instead.
You can also alter the record here,
like if you wanted to censor private
data or return an altered copy.
I'm not going to deal with filters for the rest
of the video, but here's a homework exercise.
Using this non-error filter, create a logging
config that shows normal messages to stdout,
but error messages to stderr.
You're going to need the
filter to prevent duplicates.
Okay okay, surely there are no more glaring
flaws with this logging setup, right?
At the risk of using a forbidden word
in Python let's talk about performance.
By its very nature, calling a
log function results in I/O.
If a user makes a request to my web app
and that results in 10 log messages,
I don't want to add 10 round-trips worth of time
to my logging service before I respond to my user.
But currently that's what will happen because
all logging calls are synchronous and blocking.
The solution? Use a QueueHandler
to log off the main thread.
Collecting log data isn't the slow part.
The slow part is sending
it wherever it needs to go.
A queue handler stores your log
records in a queue without blocking,
while an associated queue
listener accepts those messages
and passes them off to other
handlers in another thread.
In order to configure this, create
a new queue handler in your config.
The class is "logging.handlers.QueueHandler"
and then it accepts another list of handlers.
These are the handlers that it dispatches to,
so basically take the handlers that
you had on the root handler before,
put them here and then change the queue
handler to be your only handler on the root.
This "respect_handler_level" for
for some reason is by default false,
which results in the behavior of sending every
message to every handler regardless of log level,
so yeah, that's probably not what we want.
I'm going to set this to true
so that it does what you expect.
There's one more thing we need to
handle over here in the main file,
which is that because the queue
handler is starting a thread,
that's not something that's
going to happen automatically.
When we set up our logging we need
to manually start that thread.
We accomplish this by getting the
queue handler by name and then
if it exists we start its listener's thread.
We also register an atexit callback in
order to call the listener's stop method
and shut it down gracefully when the program ends.
Alternatively, if you want to keep
all the work inside the config,
you could also subclass the queue handler
class and make it do this stuff in its init.
And success!
We finally have a high quality,
parsable, multi-destination,
non-blocking logging setup
for our Python application.
Feels good, doesn't it?
But notice I said logging for your
"application" not your "library".
Application authors know who their users are and
know what kind of logs that they want to see.
Whereas if you're writing library code,
you don't know who your end user is and
you don't know what kind of logs they want.
Conclusion: for library code,
don't configure logging.
You can still use logging, create loggers,
log messages and other important events.
Just don't configure it with
dictConfig or any other config.
Let applications do the configuring.
If a user doesn't configure logging,
the default and expected behavior is
that warnings and above will be printed to stderr.
If a user of your library does configure logging,
then don't interfere with what
they want by adding handlers
formatters or other things
that they're not aware of.
Finally, do you remember log4j?
It's an extremely popular logging library for
Java that had a 0-day vulnerability wreak havoc
and cause absolute pandemonium in the business
world as thousands of large products and services
with millions or billions of users
instantly became vulnerable to an easy-to-do
remote arbitrary code execution vulnerability.
At the heart of the vulnerability was
a combination of logging user input,
combined with a plugin that allowed
loading remote data as Java object data.
Anyway here's Python's "makeLogRecord" function
that can be used to create log records manually.
For example "from a pickled
event received over the wire".
I'm not saying this is actively vulnerable.
but in-case "logging4p"
becomes a thing ... called it.
Thanks for watching, and
remember my company is mCoding.
So if you're still not satisfied with your
logging or other project setup, maybe we can help.
Don't be afraid to reach out.
Did you know that this entire channel
is funded completely by donations?
So huge thanks to everyone on patreon and
direct contributors for supporting the channel.
If you'd like to support the channel
go to patreon.com/mcoding and sign up.
Don't forget to subscribe and slap that
like button an odd number of times.
See you in the next one.